hey everyone it's sarah thread sterner
sorry and calm and in this video I want
to demonstrate how to Don and doff
gloves whenever wearing PPE first reform
hand hygiene then dawn gloves by pulling
each glove over the hand and extending
the cuff of the gloves over the sleeves
of the gown next remove the gloves do
not touch the outside of the gloves
because they are considered contaminated
to remove the gloves start by taking
your non-dominant gloved hand to grab
the other glove around the cuff in the
wrist area do this by using a pinching
motion to grab it peel this glove off by
turning it inside out and what it into a
ball with your gloved hand keep it
securely in your gloved hand then take
the index finger of the unloved hand and
slide it carefully under the cuff of the
gloved hand and peel the glove off the
hand by pushing the index finger forward
against the glove this will turn the
glove inside out dispose of the gloves
then perform hand hygiene okay so that
wraps up this demonstration on how to
Don and doff gloves and be sure to check
out the other videos in this series